you're good you ready all right man
emmalin will know of your courage they
all will remember me man always brother
survivors of a forced quarantine fixated
on revenge against a government who
brutally imprisoned them in society that
stood by and litter heaven the outcasts
are a cult of fanatical sadistic
survivors who seek to cause pain and
suffering through any means necessary
[Music]
you
not long after the green poison found
its way into Washington DC the JTF set
up a quarantine on Roosevelt Island the
sick were brought here to give him a
greater chance of receiving medical
treatment they needed but also to assist
in stopping the spread of the virus
although they were essentially unlocked
out forced to stay on the island a lot
of them understood that this was for the
best of intentions for the safety of
their families and the community around
them the JTF and medical staff ensured
that they were properly fed and all
necessary medical supplies were provided
it was just like a gated community the
exception being they couldn't leave
completely reliant on the personnel on
the other side of the gates they trusted
and believed everything they needed
would be provided however they also had
no foresight into what was happening off
the island as the situation started to
deteriorate on the mainland the
Roosevelt quarantine community had no
idea they just never saw it coming the
officer in charge of quarantining and
safeguarding the people on the island
was Colonel and Horn Ridgeway Ridgeway
could see what was happening on both
sites he witnessed firsthand the sick
get sicker and their numbers increasing
outside of Roseville Island he watched
as the security forces quickly lost
control of Washington DC a new society
was on the brink of collapse as
resources going to Roosevelt Island
started to drop off Ridgeway decided
that enough was enough the government
was going to lose control of the city in
the sakura lost cause and priorities
needed to change drastically he ordered
his men to up the security detail around
the island and to strengthen the
quarantine walls however it was the next
action as commanding officer of
Roosevelt Island that would change
things forever and for the community put
under his care
Ridgeway ordered a cease on all supplies
from entering the quarantine zone no
more food water or medicine was to be
administered he was leaving them to die
immediately the consequences of this
were felt within the quarantine zone
people noticed that medical personnel
stopped visiting and jtf members became
non-compliant
you're diverting supplies meant for us
aren't you don't look at me man
I different [ __ ] I'm just charging my
job as a period of time passes starving
and running out of ideas a group within
the quarantine discuss overthrowing the
captives they noticed the reduction in
God activity and decided to do something
isn't really solving the problem we can
win if we take them by surprise there's
only a handful of guards left on the
island great you're taking only one side
and we're all on it we were put here
rallying a number of people from the
quarantine community an individual
called Emmeline Shore managed to create
an uprising to overthrow the captors we
were imprisoned but we don't have to
remain prisoners you can say whatever
you want but doesn't mean we can do
anything about it
our enemies are right across that river
they tore us away from our families
[Applause]
but it's not just that
it's also the ones who signed the orders
who decided this was an acceptable
solution and it's the ones oh the ones
who stood by and let it happen
doing
I want justice and so I condemn them all
of them
and I was a male inch or a new daughter
were brought to the quarantine or
resident Island early on in the outbreak
she was forcefully separated from a
daughter during the quarantine and she
later learned that she had died due to
mistreatment the trauma of this event
built the foundation of what would later
lead to the birth of the outcasts sure
as a charismatic yet manipulative
speaker she has a way of swaying others
opinions and playing on people's
emotions which triggered their
wholehearted support regardless of all
reason and rationale abandoned by the
people who had sworn to protect them and
the brilliant persuasiveness of the new
leader Shore these survivors became
united in their quest for survival and
revenge against those who had wronged
them as the numbers grew so did their
voices and in time became easier to
convince others to take up arms and
support the cause at a time when guard
numbers were particularly low sure rally
to our newfound supporters and broke
free of the quarantine using whatever
they could find they took care of the
remaining on the island you mean to tell
me you never heard a single rumor about
how bad things were here your guilt is
clear while everyone was feeling
empowered and free of the shackles put
in place by the government she'll
continue to preaching on the current
situation they were in how they were on
their own how the government left them
to die and that everyone else in society
just sat back and let it happen any one
of them could have made a stand and
fought for them but didn't therefore
they're just as guilty as the government
we've all suffered losses we've all been
treated like feral animals we need to
make them suffer like we have no one is
exempt lacking the other factions access
to modern weapons the outcasts had to
make do with what they had at their
disposal examples of these are their
homemade flamethrowers Molotov cocktails
and the remote-control cars filled with
skill sword blades on top of us they can
be seen using bows assault rifles close
combat weapons basically anything they
could find or loot off other factions to
easily identify each other members of
the group with scarves bandanas shirts
and even hoods made from the yellow
quarantine plastic taken from the camp
it was during this time that sure found
out that she has a rare asymptomatic
carrier of the virus she doesn't suffer
from the sight of the virus but still
carries it with a new body and can
easily transmit it to others this only
adds to the court like behavior of the
group that will start to form around it
but also it provides the outcasts with a
new strategy in their mission to create
havoc in Washington DC basically their
main objective stays the same except now
with Emmeline sure as their leader they
have an endless supply of the virus in
their strategy of how to inflict the
most pain has changed the goal was to
spread the doll flu throughout the
healthy citizens of the city a second
outbreak of the virus that started at
all the outcasts roam the city and
indiscriminately kill and infect other
survivors as revenge for the
mistreatment they suffered at the hands
of the government while forcibly
quarantined especially the closest
settlement the campus with this newfound
weapon the outcasts started coming up
with creative yet sadistic ways of
infecting the healthy in one instance
there was a leader nicknamed the brutal
who injected puppies of the green poison
and then released in near an elementary
school
oh god damn it stakes of course it does
what do you expect how many of them in
there I don't know 15 I wasn't counting
you're killing off my left one girl
alive well send her off to the campus to
tell them what she witnessed guys kept
thinking Emmaline's idea not mine
the outcasts relationship with other
hostile factions isn't particularly
surprising they load the true sense as
they were the ones who were directly
involved with their imprisonment and
suffering yet despite this they're not
actively at war with them perhaps there
is an understanding that they are simply
to outgun to take on the superior
training and equipment of the true sons
however they can still be seen attacking
patrolling units and executing survivors
loyal to your commander I'm just trying
to survive true Sun seemed like the
safest be useful to you you expect me to
trust a man who would switch sides so
easily give me a chance in-game we first
meet the outcasts in the DCD
headquarters they've set up a lab there
and are using this facility to produce
smallpox samples that they plan to
spread throughout the city the division
makes short work of us destroying the
lab and virus subtles next we find them
to Potomac event center where we task of
capturing the outcasts strategist again
they were quickly wiped out
after several more defeats at the hands
of the division the outcasts fall back
to their final stronghold where it all
began on Roosevelt Island
after a grueling fight the division
finally found Emmeline Shaw and she was
being asked order onto a boat to escape
the area but after a last-ditch effort
involved in wave after wave of outcasts
the division managed to detonate the
explosives on the boat along with
annoying Shaw the outcasts were absolute
in their devotion to their ideals even
if it was to spread death disease and
misery wherever they go as revenge
against the society that let him suffer
I'm almost completely certain that we
haven't seen the last of the up casts
and even Emmeline Shaw the last we saw
of her just seemed a little bit off to
me we saw someone being escorted onto a
boat and we assumed that it was her but
we didn't actually see her up close even
during the final fight we didn't get to
hear a peep out of her and some would
expect a final word or a preach of how
they were just in what they were doing
but something along those lines in fact
we didn't encounter her throughout the
whole stronghold I wouldn't be surprised
if she was long gone from the island
before we got there I will be covering
the outcast more in a future video there
are just too many questions and things
popping up the heaven be answered for
example have you seen the secret
underground AL room
weapon together to avoid detection
the outcasts came to be through an
individual who was stricken by grief who
also happened to be charismatic and able
to work on people's vulnerabilities in
order to have them follow their beliefs
but given the situation they were in
sick starving to death locked off from
what's happening in the outside world
having watched people close to you die
because of the actions of people who are
supposed to be looking after your
well-being if someone had a solution to
the problem and managed to break you
free from the prison would you be
somewhat open to the idea of following
this person after all everyone else has
just lifted to die okay guys that's it
for this video I hope you've enjoyed it
if you have any leads or more
information regarding the outcasts or
any of the factions really just let me
know through the comments or through the
energy and discord Cheers I won't not
for me it ends when I wake up and this
was all just a terrible dream and my
daughter is still here
and she didn't die alone calling out for
me or too far gone to notice I wasn't
there beside her nothing gonna make that
right not ever and until it's right it
won't end
you